evalúa la expresión 4 en elevado a la
primera potencia menos 2 n elevado a la
potencia 0 para en igual a 1 y en igual
a 5
hagamos primero en iguala 1 voy a
reescribir la expresión donde veamos n
ponemos 1 así es que esto es igual a 4
por 1 elevado a la potencia 1 menos dos
por uno elevado a la potencia cero donde
vimos una n pusimos un 1 aquí teníamos n
a la primera potencia pusimos una la
primera potencia y recuerda para hacer
las operaciones en orden tenemos pendás
luego a poner por aquí tenemos primero
paréntesis luego la ex ponencia acción
luego multiplicación y división que
tienen la misma prioridad finalmente
tenemos la suma o adición y la resta o
sustracción que tienen la misma
prioridad así es que vamos a los
exponentes primero pues aquí no tenemos
paréntesis
así es que evaluamos primero uno a la
potencia 1 y cuando elevamos algo a la
potencia 1 eso es igual a ese algo deja
de ponerlo por aquí y si tengo x elevado
a la potencia 1 esto es igual a x así es
que 1 elevado la potencia 1 es igual a 1
tenemos entonces que esto va a ser 4
por uno menos dos por uno elevado a la
potencia cero ahora cualquier número
distinto de cero elevado a la potencia
cero es igual a uno sí tenemos entonces
x elevado a la potencia cero esto que es
igual si te digo que x es distinto de
cero entonces deben saber inmediatamente
que x eleva la potencia cero es igual a
uno y te digo que x tiene que ser
distinto de cero pues será elevado a la
potencia cero
esto es indefinido así es que esto es
generalmente aceptado como indefinido y
quizás en un vídeo próximo explicaré por
qué esto es indefinido pues por un lado
hay buenos argumentos de por qué debería
ser cero pues 0 elevado a cualquier
número es siempre cero pero también hay
un argumento válido porque debería ser
uno pues cualquier número elevado a la
potencia cero es 1 es por eso que esto
en general se considera indefinido y con
eso en mente 1 elevado a la potencia 0
va a ser simplemente 1 cualquier número
distinto de cero elevado a la potencia
cero es 1 tenemos entonces cuatro por
uno es cuatro menos dos por uno es igual
a dos finalmente 4 - 2
2 ahora hagamos lo mismo con n igual a 5
esto es 4 por 5 a la potencia 1 - 2 por
5 a la potencia 0 ya lo mismo 5 a la
potencia 15 a la potencia 1 es igual a 5
déjame hacerlo mejor con otro color
ahora sí con este color 5 a la potencia
1 es igual a 5 y 5 a la potencia 0 es
igual a 1 entonces ahora tenemos cuatro
por 5 menos 2 por 1 y esto va a ser
igual 4 por 5 es 20 menos 2 por 1 es 22
por unos 220 menos 2 es igual a 18 listo
hemos terminado